all right um hi everyone welcome back to
cs330 um today we'll be talking about
lifelong learning and this lecture will
be a little different than the previous
lectures we've had
it will be much more open-ended
um
and i think a little more interactive as
well and this is because the topic
itself is much more open-ended as well
all right so the plan for today is um as
following
uh we'll start with the lifelong
learning problem statement and we'll try
to see why this on its by itself is
quite challenging already
um then we'll think of some basic
approaches that can allow us to
address the problem of lifelong learning
we can we will also think about how we
can do better than these basic
approaches and then we'll revisit the
problem um
by looking at it from the metal learning
perspective
all right
so i wanted to sort of a brief review of
the problem statements that we have been
considering so far
in the class
and one of them was multitask learning
and the problem statement was as
following we're given a set of tasks up
front
uh we can train on these tasks and then
we'll be evaluated based on the
performance on those exact same tasks so
we're just trying to learn to solve a
set of tasks
and then we also talked about the metal
learning problem statement
that is a little bit different so in
this case we are given an id task
distribution and we are tasked to learn
a new task efficiently so we're given a
batch of data with many different tasks
and based on that we need to
be able to learn how to learn quickly so
that given a new task we can quickly
adjust to it and learn how to do it
all right so these are the problem
statements we have been we have been
considering so far
but um in many real world settings the
the setting is actually a little bit
different
so rather than having this batch of data
or batch of different tasks that we can
pre-train on either in the multi-task or
meta-learning
it would look more or less like this so
we would have tasks that are given to us
but that are not given to us up front
right off the bat instead they're coming
to us in sequence so for instance we
need to
learn how to
walk first and then after we can do this
we will start learning how to run and
after we do this we are given another
task and we kind of
keep keep going and keep learning new
tasks that come in sequence rather than
having this
this big batch of data and tasks up
front
all right so a few examples just to
show you what what i mean by this new
problem statement
um so for example a student learning
concepts in school as uh as an example
of uh
of this real world setting that is more
sequential or rather than
being given all the different classes
and all the different
levels of in a particular class
you're
you're given different concepts in a
sort of curriculum so you'll first learn
how to do algebra one and then you'll do
algebra too you're not given all of
those all of that knowledge at once
another example is a deployed image
classification system that is trying to
learn from a stream of images that come
from users
and here things that can change over
time is are things such as user
preferences or the images that the users
tend to take the the preferences and and
the images might change over time and
the algorithm should be able to adjust
to that
another another robotics example is a
robot acquiring acquiring an
increasingly large set of skills in
different environments
so in this case we can imagine a robot
that is um initially deployed let's say
in the kitchen and it's doing all kinds
of different tasks in the kitchen but
after a while we wanted to also clean
the bathroom
so in that case we would want the robot
to be able to quickly transition to that
new skill and as it's given more and
more tasks and skills in the sequence
should every new task should come easier
and easier
another one is a virtual assistant
learning to help different users with
different tasks at different points in
time
so in that case we would want to have an
assistant that can adjust to our
preferences over time we don't want to
have an assistant that was just free
trained on something and it never
responds to us and learns from our uh
interactions with it uh but it should be
something that can uh kind of quickly
adjust to our preferences and understand
that better so that the longer we
interact with it the better it gets
and then the last example uh
we have here is a doctor's assistant
aiding in medical decision making where
things that can change over time is
you know the the diseases that
the doctor's assistant would need to be
able to deal with such as covet 19 that
wasn't really around a few years ago
so it needs to be able to adjust his
decisions over time and hopefully with
every new disease or with every new
patient that's able to get better and
better
all right so um
before we uh jump into a little exercise
about the problem statement i wanted to
introduce a little bit of terminology
so overall we'll be concerned with
sequential learning settings and people
refer to it with different names so
such as online learning lifelong
learning continual learning increment
incremental learning and streaming data
um often they mean slightly different
things
um
and it's important when you when you
read papers on on lifelong learning to
kind of uh really understand the problem
statement that the address are trying to
solve because very often even though
they are called the same the problem
statement is slightly different
but overall we will assume that all of
these terms
can be
try to refer to the same sequential
learning setting the lifelink learning
setting and we'll discuss the problem
statement in a second
it's important to note that this is
distinct from sequence data or
sequential decision making so an example
of sequential data is for example
a corpora of text where
we might still want to learn a text
generator that
was trained on a large batch of data
and the data itself is sequential so
you're generating one word after another
um but it's not really a sequential
learning setting in the sense that
you're not given new tasks over time
you're still pre-trained on a large set
of tasks and data
and then sequential decision making we
talked about this in the context of
reinforcement learning this is a
situation where
we can make decisions um or we have to
make sequential decisions uh but we can
still do for example using reinforcement
learning but we can still do this from
an offline data set
that we get to pre-train on so it
doesn't necessarily mean that it's a
sequential learning setting where we're
given new tasks as we as we go
there's a question on the chat asking uh
lifelong learning seems similar to
active learning what are the differences
between the two
yeah so i think um
active learning some people refer to
some aspects of lifelong learning as
active learning so one aspect of active
learning that
or one one aspect of learning that makes
it more active is that we are searching
for data that would be particularly
useful
um
for the algorithm to know about so for
example an interactive system that is
trying to query the user for the data
that it's most uncertain about it's an
example of an active learning system
um
i think a lifelong learning system can
have this property as well
but lifelong assumes that that that
sequential
um
that these tasks there's there's
multiple of them and you kind of as as
you get new tasks you shouldn't forget
about the old ones and as you get more
tasks you should be getting better and
better at the new tasks that you are
getting so there are like slightly
different axes of the problem but i
think you can build a lifelong active
learning system
where you do both where the active
learning system can ask for uh the data
that is the most useful to it and it can
also do it over its lifetime
all right
um cool so we'll do a little exercise
right now
um
and this is so that uh we can come up
with a lifelong learning problem
statement
all right
so the exercise is as following
um i'll ask you to pick an example
setting and i'll give you the i'll put
on a slide the examples that i just
talked about
um
and then i'll ask you to discuss the
problem statement in your breakout room
so we'll split in breakup rooms i will
do this in a second um we'll do it such
that there's three to four students per
room
and um i would ask you if the first
letter of your first name is closer to
the beginning of the alphabet
you will be the one responsible for
taking the notes and then presenting it
to the to the rest of the class
um
so the problem statement the the
questions that i would like you to focus
on are the following first how would you
set up an experiment to develop and test
your lifelong learning algorithm and
this is very open-ended so
kind of use your creativity and kind of
think what how would you set up an
experiment to develop and test the life
and learning algorithm
second question is what are the
desirable and or required properties of
such algorithm
and thirdly how would you evaluate such
a system
all right
so
here i'll show you the
uh this will work
okay here are the example settings that
i talked about just uh
a few slides ago so you're welcome to
use any of these if that helps for your
discussion or if you're feeling um you
know particularly creative feel free to
come up with your own
uh this is very encouraged
and uh we'll do this for five minutes
um so i'll try to split you into
breakout rooms right now
uh and we'll meet in five minutes and
we'll have the the presenters from each
group um tell us what they what they
came up with
all right so
let me split you into the breakup rooms
all right
i think all of you um should have been
invited to join breakout rooms so please
join them and i'll see you in five
minutes
all right so
when it's passed i will close the rooms
now
oh double closing in one minute okay
all right and
breakout rooms are all closed
welcome back everybody
i hope you get
good discussions
um
so
i will be asking uh for a person from
each room to tell us a little bit about
um what they what they've discussed
and i'll i'll try to take notes so i
have my little stylus here
and i hope you can read my handwriting
um
but i'll take notes and we'll be talking
about desirable properties and
considerations as well as the evaluation
setup
um
and i just wanted to um to
let you know that uh
the the the problem setting as one of
the hardest parts of lifelong learning
um
challenge or lifelong learning the topic
of lifelong learning so uh this is a
really difficult exercise
um but with that let's get started so
um i'll ask the
person from room number one to tell us
all about deservable properties and
evaluation setup
uh sure um
this
from room one i believe
um
so we chose
the setting of an
image classification system
uh so
our experiment would be uh you know
first we
decided on like a data set so
we chose
uh the
the
agnes data set
um
and our experiment is we want to sort of
build up
the knowledge of the classifier being
able to distinguish between
um each of like the digits um
it's kind of like an incremental so we
begin with the classifier being able to
discriminate between the first digit and
um
let's say like
uh
digit number two
and then we can
do like the testing um to sort of almost
in classes but then in like the next
round
we
have a discriminate between uh
class one and two and then kind of three
and four and then we um
create like but the test on all the
digits so we kind of do that
incrementally
and then the goal would be to sort of
it can build
up
good knowledge quickly
okay yeah that makes a lot of sense so
you're learning incrementally
and you're given
uh you start with the digit one and then
you're given the next digit over time
and uh
what are the desirable properties of
such an algorithm so you wanted to
learn
so be learning increasingly
yes
and
so so what are the other properties that
you would want to
have
yeah um
i think the ability to
learn
what is needed to learn quickly i guess
so
because of the new kind of digits um
each kind of digit has its own kind of
set like of
different kinds of characteristics so i
guess maybe being able to learn quickly
kind of like a few shopkins
okay so with every new digit that should
learn quicker and quicker
okay
and uh and how would you evaluate this
algorithm specifically so you would have
i guess i should have written that in
this part here
you would have the endless digits
and you are measuring what exactly
yeah so um
i guess
this specific metric um
i guess we would evaluate the accuracy
um
assuming that like the decent i believe
is balanced but i i think the goal is
kind of like how like a student
um has like a midterm and like a final
it should be
assessed on
sort of the classes it's seen
um
as opposed to like okay i just learned
class four we should just about on class
four exceed
um
be able to
do well on all
the digits
i believe i gotta see
right so it should be evaluated in all
the classes that it's seen so far
yeah
okay and you would you would evaluate
based on the accuracy of all of those
okay that makes a lot of sense cool is
there anything else you would want to
add
okay
all right great thank you um right i'll
ask the room number two and i think
some people don't remember their room
number so just if your group hasn't been
called yet you know just go ahead and
say something
i believe i was part of room number two
and
i can go like so we discussed about the
problem setting of uh you know robot
navigation uh indoors
so uh when you have robot inside the
inside your apartment your the layout of
your apartment keeps changing
continuously you keep moving furnitures
one place to another or you could even
move from one apartment to another and
ideally you would want the same robot
to learn how to navigate in the new um
in the new apartment
and uh one of the ways you could train
such a
robot is in like gibson environment or
habitat environment for example there
are different rooms uh would be
considered a different tasks
um
and uh one of the evaluation
um metric could be like you know
shortest path
taken from source to destination
or like even different goals could be
you know different uh tasks
for example you wanted to navigate to
kitchen or some other room um
things like that
okay yeah that makes a lot of sense so
you would be checking how long it takes
for it to find the shortest path to the
destination is that right
yeah how long the path would be
how i mean
like i don't know how to define shortest
path here uh what would you compare it
with
um
but
yeah i mean
essentially uh when you having the let's
say the furniture layout changes from
one to another
um you'd still want to find um
like uh the most efficient pack from
source to destination
right
and uh
like one of the ways i can think of is
you would use something like a star or
something and you would want to do
better than that
um
but yeah um shortest path could be one
evaluation
right okay that makes a lot of sense and
what are so given that this is a
lifelong learning algorithm and you'll
be as you said you'll be given one room
at the time
uh what are the desirable properties of
such an algorithm what would you want
that algorithm to do
um
uh
yeah um i don't know if
i don't know uh
and
yeah you can jump in
but
after that so basically what we were
discussing is it might happen that when
the like the
uh environment changes like dome changes
or the furniture changes so the bot
mates may get confused maybe
so it should be able to like ask
the human
uh like what direction should i be so
basically it should have the ability to
somehow quantify the uncertainty and if
it's better than some threshold it
should be able to ask it like then
incorporate that feedback
like the new territory
okay so we should quantify uncertainty
and uh should ask for feedback
great
um
right is there anything else that you
would like to add
oh yeah i can't think of anything else
okay great thank you this is this is
great um right room number three
yeah hi this is um we have uh selected
uh one of the examples listed in
the slides
uh actually we picked the number eight
uh student learning concepts in school
um
but maybe this can be applied also for
uh kind of digital
learner uh which we faded content right
so um we argued a little bit for uh for
this example that
there might be kind of two
setups one is more explorative so
similar like a reinforcement learning
environment and another one which is um
more of a supervised kind of approach
and
and that is based on
let's say similar environments like in
different parts of the world where
some some knowledge or some schools
let's say are more spoon-feeding rather
than some other places where they let
you
experiment and learn
so one
one of the
um
desirable properties and considerations
here is that you have some learning
objectives so you know what
you want to learn
in different kind of milestones
and
and a given time frame to learn those uh
learning objectives
and um
every second or every
learning objective that is coming after
the
after the the previous one
needs to be based on knowledge uh
historical knowledge that you have
learned before
uh so it's incremental
and so you're it's kind of given to you
in some kind of curriculum
yeah and
one of the ways to evaluate that is to
stop let's say the training carry out
evaluation tests
but these evaluation tests
need to be
again subject to the to the setup
either explorative and therefore use the
knowledge that you have learned
on these sort of
explorative questions to understand
whether it's like critical thinking
testing right or
just to
find out for example what you have
learned from from the previous knowledge
you can carry out the past within a
given time frame
yeah okay
yeah i think that makes a lot of sense
so you would stop training at a certain
point and then you would test the
ability of the algorithm to reason given
all the previous knowledge
that's right that's right yeah
um
i think this is great um is there
anything else you would like to
add um no this is what we had the time
to discuss for yeah okay great thank you
um
group number four
yeah so um the
sort of situation that we chose was
a robot that's going from room to room
and it's recognizing objects that it
sees
and
uh i think a key characteristic that we
identified is that the data sets
constantly changing like the
distribution's changing
um and i need to be able to adapt to
this so both like learn
new
types of i guess like new instances that
i may um encounter but also
um
i guess like a property is that we'd
like for it to be able to
still remember like previous uh objects
that it's recognized and so you know if
it hasn't seen an object in the last
like five rooms it can still recognize
an object from the first room
um
and that
ideally as it goes through the rooms it
can learn correctly not as new objects
better
um but we identify the like challenge of
this or like a factor and this is how
similar
i just like how similar like those like
future tasks are compared to
um previous tasks so
um like if future objects are a lot
harder you know might not work out very
well
right right that makes a lot of sense
and so how would you evaluate
these properties for example learning
new objects better or whether you're
good at
um uh
whether you have some kind of memory how
would you evaluate that
yeah i think um you would sort of treat
it as like a few shot learner where
every time it moves to a new um
moves to a new room and encounters
almost like a it's not i guess it's not
really a new task but there are new
instances that it has to recognize so um
i i guess yeah you can evaluate your
keyshot learner you give it just a few
examples and see how if it can i guess
it'd be accuracy having only seen a few
examples of new types of objects
yeah
i think that makes a lot of sense
uh
i can see it here
all right great anything else you want
to ask
i think that was all yeah that's pretty
challenging yeah yeah
thank you
all right room number five which i think
at some point we reassign people to
other rooms so either five or six
i was actually five in the beginning and
then i got assigned to four i see okay
great then room number six
um so the context we were looking at
was was one of the
um
given ones with
uh young robot trying to learn uh a
bunch of different tasks and series um
started picturing lighting on the you
know i'm going to feel like different
objects and play different instruments
or
that was kind of an image little images
we had in their heads
um
and then the
uh
the setup to develop and tests would be
uh they have multiple rooms in each room
it's just trying to do a different task
or you add objects to the same room and
it's learning to
do different tasks in that room pretty
similar to some of uh
other stuff you've heard um
discussed um one one discussion we had
that um i thought was kind of
interesting was like okay so we had this
idea that a lot of times you wanted to
not be forgetting the old tasks but we
were wondering what should happen in
those cases where like say see there's
something equivalent to like learning a
bad habit or learning something that
might then becomes you know inadvisable
later or something like you need some
how do you deal with kind of that
uh maybe there's times when it makes
sense to forget some some skill or to
like really really particular skills and
like how do you how you deal with
uh
that
process was something we weren't really
sure
how exactly you would you would want to
do that or like set up evaluations
for that um
yeah and in terms of desirable
properties it was like most time
probably don't forget the old ones
although there was you know the
discussion along that and then
that kind of sense of you want to be
able to leverage
uh old tasks to more quickly learn new
tasks and you know sort of mammal-like
idea
um
uh and then in terms of evaluation
uh
when we're thinking about like you you
can do something where you're shuffling
the tasks and seeing how different
you know time
uh
like
if you
how the order of the tasks you learn
affects how well you learn them um
to
you know see
if you really are leveraging old ones if
there's and also just doing them those
individual tasks
yeah i think that makes a lot of sense
and the comment about being careful
about what to remember i think this is
really insightful i haven't thought
about this this is a really good point
um
so you would see how the order affects
tasks
for the ordering of classic effects and
performance
um
great and then you would also evaluate
some kind of backward transfer so how
good are you at not forgetting the older
stuff is that right
yeah yeah although with
the caveat of voice
maybe it's like a nuanced process
if you're learning like a change
preference or something but yeah some
sort of you want to retain probably most
of most of what you've heard
yeah great um thank you um and we have
the last room i believe room number
seven
yeah i can speak for room seven um
so we also talked about uh kind of a
robot learning
uh multiple tasks uh or like continually
learning more and more tests
um
and so
kind of our idea behind it was we wanted
um
the
the agent to be able to
still perform well on all tests
but be quick
to pick up new tasks and get them to a
point that we that would be like
good for that task
so we were thinking maybe you would
compare it between
the end result of training for the task
alone
versus how far you could get or how much
faster you could get to a similar point
um having accumulated the skills of
previous tests or accumulate some kind
of middle state from previous tasks
so you would evaluate it both on
end performance
and on how quickly you reach end
performance
um given how many previous tests you've
seen
right right okay so that will be the end
performance and also how how long it
takes to get there
yeah kind of the idea being that it's
built up some
skills along the way or some kind of
middle amount of of state that it can be
quick to use
right right yeah i think that makes a
lot of sense um
great is there anything else you would
like to add
i think that's
that was what we spent the most time on
was this kind of evaluation setup
awesome um thank you um is there anybody
else
who was in a different room that we
haven't talked about yet that would like
to talk about
their thought process or discussion
all right i think there shouldn't be
anyone so that's great
um thank you very much this is this is
really really
a lot of fun for me definitely just to
hear your thoughts about this and i
think a lot of them are along the lines
of things that that you think about when
you try to design a system like this and
uh i think one thing we can notice here
is that uh there's quite a lot of
diversity in what uh desirable
properties and considerations are
and how we would evaluate them
uh we talked about things such as you
know coming up with the right or doing
things in a certain curriculum which is
more about how we order these tasks we
talked about the notion of memory and
how we should be able to uh still know
how to do things that we learned in the
past but at the same time we would want
to get better at learning uh new tasks
as we know more and more
and then we talked about different
evaluation setups and this was i thought
really fun so different robot navigation
settings uh also more real life settings
such as students in school
um
robots with uh not necessarily doing
navigation but just handling different
tasks or objects mnus digits and all
kinds of things um so thanks a lot
um
and i
did that exercise myself a little bit
too
and came up with a few variations
which i think a lot of you came up with
as well so let me list those
so first the
um the task and data order might matter
as i think someone said in the student
case where we might want to have a
curriculum of tasks or one build on top
of the previous one but we could also
imagine these tasks being given to you
id
or uh they can be given to you in an
adversarial fashion so for example
you're playing with a game with someone
and that that other agent is trying to
uh find a strategy that would uh
that that uh that is trying to to beat
you so it's basically uh that's trying
to find your weakness
um or something that is predictable
where such as for example seasons where
you can tell that there is a change
coming
and you can predict when when a new task
or data distribution will come
another aspect that we haven't talked
that much about is
whether there are discrete task
boundaries or continuous shifts right so
we can imagine discrete task boundaries
where for example you have different
subjects in school and you know that one
subject ends and another begins we can
also imagine continuous shifts when the
robot is playing with a bunch of objects
and then these objects are slowly being
exchanged or for example in the
navigation scenario the rooms are slowly
changing and it's hard to tell at which
point you're given a different task
there's also a question whether these
are known to you or not
so you can know that something changed
someone can tell you you know now you're
in a different room you have to learn or
um you might just experience this and
you need to adjust to that
and some considerations in terms of the
evaluation is
model performance i think a lot of you
mentioned this data efficiency some
people mentioned that as well
and then things such as computational
resources uh and memory
but there are also other things and
we'll talk about this in a second such
as privacy or interpretability fairness
and a lot of them or test time computer
memory a lot of them apply to a general
machine learning problems to general
machine learning problems but some of
them are
more specific to or more common in
lifelong learning scenario
all right so we can already tell from
this exercise and even from the slide
that there's a substantial variety in
the problem statement and this is a
really important point that i would like
you to remember when you read papers on
lifelong learning
all right so
i'll try to create a general supervised
online learning problem
given those considerations but i'll try
to make it quite specific
so we'll be given data points over time
and the problem would look as following
we'll observe the data point then we'll
try to predict the label for the data
point this is a supervised online
learning problem
and then we'll get to observe the true
label
all right and if the setting is id then
our distribution will be not dependent
on time so it doesn't matter at which
point you're sampling from the
distribution p of x or p of y even x
you'll be given you'll be something from
the same distribution
but we can also consider a problem where
the distribution is dependent on time so
depending when you sample from it
it will look differently
and then there's also a streaming
setting where the assumption is that you
cannot store the current sample that you
see
so there could be various reasons for
this for example it's just too big and
you don't necessarily have the memory to
store that or you don't have enough
computational resources such as for
example when you have to classify videos
really quickly you don't really want to
store them
uh there are also privacy considerations
so
you could be in the in the case of the
medical assistant um you don't you're
not allowed to store the the patient's
data but you need to be able to use that
to make better production
or when you want to study neural memory
mechanisms where we as humans don't
really have hard drives where we can
save our data to
so in general the streaming setting is
true in some cases but in many cases
these are not necessarily the
considerations that we we have to
consider in a lot of the examples that
we talked about
these were not the most important
constraints
and in particular remember that for
example in reinforcement learning we use
replay buffers um almost for for any off
policy algorithm so there's it's fairly
easy to store the data for us
all right um so what do we want from a
lifelong learning algorithm
um and there is a particular there are
two particular measures that are um i
think quite principle that it's useful
to to know about one of them is regret
or minimal regret so we want a regret
that would grow slowly with the number
of data points or the number of tasks
and regret this has a strict
mathematical definition and is defined
as the cumulative loss of the learner
minus the commodity loss of the best
learner in hindsight
right so what that means is a formula
that looks like this where the first
part um
the part
let me just take my
real quick
so the part right here
is cumulative loss of the learner so
here we have our loss that depends on
the uh the loss for the current task l
team or for the current data point
and we have the parameters theta so we
don't have control over that loss
and this is just something that measures
the performance of our algorithm
and then we have our parameters theta
that we get to pick at time step t
and this is what our algorithm can
produce so this is what we do have
control over
and then we do the cumulative loss
across all of the data points or all of
the tasks
minus the best uh the commotive loss of
the best learner in hindsight so if we
knew all of the tasks up front we would
and we would find the best theta for all
of them how would the difference grow
with the number of tasks with new tasks
right so this is the notion of regret
and
the goal usually is so one one point
here is that it's really difficult to
evaluate in practice because you would
need to run this every single time
but it's useful for analysis for
different algorithms
um and
one thing to note is that regret that
grows linearly in t is trivial and um
can you tell me why or can you give me
an example of a regret like this
um
or rather of a learner that achieves a
linear regret in t
please either raise your hand
or just speak up
any ideas about the regret that will
grow lingerie
all right this is this might be a little
tricky um
so let me try to give you one example
um so for instance if we had an
algorithm that trains each task from
scratch so every time you get a new task
you train it from scratch then this term
would grow linearly with t so at every
task assuming that they're of the same
difficulty it will be getting
kind of the regret will be getting
bigger and bigger by the same amount so
it will grow linearly with time
or with tasks
all right is this does this make sense
more or less
or are there any questions
right so
um
i think you can so it kind of depends on
the setting you can either consider this
as a task where you're given a single
data point that can be also considered a
task but let's say these are this is the
data point so t is the
small t is the current data point
and our
theta t are the parameters that your
lifelong learning algorithm can come up
with
um for the particular data point t
right and then the capital t is
across all the data points that you get
to see and you get to see them in
sequence
so now the first part is telling you
what's the cumulative loss so the loss
that you sum up over each one of those
of the data points for uh your
parameters theta t
and then the the second the second part
of this equation tells you what is the
best the commotive loss of the best
learner in hindsight so across all the
data points if you saw all of the data
points at once and you you you could
find the best parameters data for those
uh what would be the commodity loss for
that
right so this is kind of like our our
oracle the best that we could do
right so the reason why
an algorithm that would train
um
on each data point from scratch has a
linear regret
um is because assuming that each data
point is as difficult as the previous
one um
that term will grow linearly linearly
linearly
right so basically at every point you
will be getting a constant loss
and then you will be summing that up
does that make sense
yeah okay
right cool
all right so there is one other measure
that uh i would like to introduce and
this is um
positive and negative transfer and this
is maybe a little bit easier so the
positive forward transfer
is
something that a lot of you mentioned in
the um during the discussion is where
the previous task cause you to do better
on future tasks right so that means that
as you get more tasks you're getting
better and better on future tasks
and this is compared to learning future
tasks from scratch
and then the positive backward transfer
would mean that the current task cause
you to do better on previous tasks right
so as you learn more and more you are
getting better at the tasks that you
have already seen
and this is also compared to learning
past tests from scratch and if you want
to talk about instead of the positive
transfer
you want to talk about the negative
transfer then you need to change the
word better to the word worse and that
will be the definition of that
there are a couple questions about
regret in the chat so the first question
is within your regret can we say that
there is no or minimal knowledge
learning or transfer from previous tasks
yeah yeah exactly so if there is no
positive transfer or there is nothing
that you're learning from each task as
it comes
then you're getting linear regression
that basically means that you're not
really learning from the process of
getting these tests
is asking can regret be negative if
choosing just a single theta ends up
being two respectively
incredibly negative i see so i think the
question is
if that if a single theta is not really
able to capture
uh all of the tasks at once
can can we do better than that oracle
i think usually in regret we assume that
the the the part on the right side is
the oracle so we assume that we have
enough parameters to find
the right setting to find the minimum
loss so i think usually we don't
consider negative regress
all right
cool are there any other questions at
this point so we talked about the
problem statement and we talked quite a
lot about this so i wanted to tell you a
little bit about some basic approaches
that we can use to tackle that um but
before we go there are there any other
questions
all right
if there are no questions then let's
jump into the approaches
so i'll tell you about some very very
basic approaches so it might seem very
very obvious that this is what you
should be doing but still i think it's
important to write them out
um so one approach is that we can just
store all the data that we've seen so
far and train on it
right that's relatively simple and that
actually has a name and the name is
follow the leader algorithm
right so this is
whatever you have seen so far you just
keep adding to it and you will take that
buffer of data and you'll train on it
so the advantage of that is that this
actually has a pretty strong baseline uh
you're training in all the tasks that
you have seen so far you're in this kind
of batch-like setting
and this usually works really well
this is really computationally intensive
because with every new task or
remembering your data point
you would have to do the computation in
all of the tasks
one thing that can help here is
continuous fine tuning instead so you
can warm start your model from the
previous iteration and just perform fine
tuning um instead of uh training
everything from scratch every time you
get a new data point
and it can be also quite memory
intensive because you have to load the
entire dataset every time
but that yeah that depends all right
then um another approach that is
extremely simple is that you can take a
gradient step on the data point you
observe so you get a new data point you
have your model you can just take the
gradient step on that data point
and it also has a name and that name is
stochastic gradient descent as hopefully
most of us are familiar with
so
we'll be every time we get the new data
we'll perform
the gradient step on it
and it will allow us to move towards the
um
towards the direction that minimizes the
loss
right this is very computationally cheap
we we just need to perform one gradient
step on the data point
it requires zero memory so we can just
take the compute the gradient take it
and that's it we don't need to store
that data
um but that's subject to negative
backward transfer right so if we only
get to do gradient steps on the new
trade on the new data that is coming in
that might mean that we can forget about
all the old data that we've seen
and because of this that might lead to
us forgetting about what we've done
previously
and uh this is often referred to as
forgetting or
also referred to as catastrophic
forgetting dependent on the application
and uh
i think we we also know from stochastic
gradient descent very often we need to
do multiple epochs we need to go over
the data multiple times and it requires
quite some time to
for for this two to converge so it'd be
quite a small learning algorithm
all right so these are um
basic approaches that kind of
we can think of straight away and i
wanted to show you one implementation of
such a very simple approach in the
reinforcement learning scenario
so this will be a very simple continual
reinforcement learning algorithm
and this is work done by
ryan julian
and encoders so in this work we have
seven robots that collected 500 000
grasps and this is the similar setting
that you have seen when we were
discussing the qt of paper when we were
talking about q learning
so we have these robots and that then we
can evaluate how well they can do
grasping we we train the policy using
reinforcement learning and uh given a
specific bin and this set of objects
they can achieve 86
success rate on grasping these objects
okay but then we can also find a
scenario where when the algorithm is not
that good so for example in this case we
threw a few transparent bottles into the
bin
and you know these are visually
challenging objects and the algorithm
did not perform nearly as well so the
evaluation performance of that algorithm
was just 49
right so
we can consider this as like a very
little sliver of a lifelong learning
scenario where you're presented with a
slightly new condition or you're in a
slightly new environment or in this case
you're dealing with slightly different
objects and you need to adapt to it
quickly
right so
the the kind of mental model that you
can have in mind something like this we
have our pre-training task that we
trained all these robots on this was
this 580 000 grasps
we have the old data that is stored
somewhere on disk and we have a policy
that we trained using some offline
reinforcement learning algorithm
and then we have a new data
that we for example use to compute that
number 49
and now we need to use that new data
combine it with the policy that we have
so far and perform some kind of
adaptation procedure so that we are
getting better at this new task
right so this is the the adaptation
procedure that we came up with and this
is really really simple so let me
quickly go over this
so
here um on the left here you see the the
base data set so this is the data set
that we originally
created
and this was
around 600 8 000 grasps
and this achieved 86 success rate as we
as we mentioned before
so this was then used to use the qt for
the in the qt algorithm to train a queue
function
so to train our from that we can get our
policy that can achieve that that 86
success rate
and then we'll use that policy to
collect a little bit more data in a
slightly different scenario so for
example in transparent bubbles or we
tried a few other scenarios as well and
that would yield a much lower success
rate
and we'll collect a little bit of data
in that scenario so less than 800 grasps
then we'll mix the data
50 50 with the the base data set that we
had
and then we will
fine tune our q function based on that
mixture of data that we collected
all right so we have the data set here
and now we are fine tuning our queue
function so we are warm starting the
model from the previous q function
and we are fine-tuning it using the data
and from that we get the adapted q
function that hopefully will perform
better at that task
right
okay so
we evaluated this in a few different
scenarios that were quite challenging
for the robot
so here are the scenarios so on the left
this is the pre-training it achieved 86
percent and then we're looking for
scenarios where the robot wouldn't
perform as well so one is harsh lighting
conditions
there are transparent balls that we
talked about as well
we also found that checkerboard backing
was really confusing for the robot that
would very often try to grasp at the
edges of the checkerboard
and then we also changed the morphology
a little bit so we extended the gripper
to be a little bit longer and we also
offset the gripper a little bit to the
right where you can see that the gripper
is supposed to be here but it's a little
bit offset by 10 centimeters
and here at the top you can see the
results of the base policy running in
these conditions so you can see that in
every single time it's quite a bit lower
than 86 and 86
and after the simple fine tuning
procedure
these numbers went up by quite a bit
so we have a simple find very very
simple fine tuning procedure that
continues to use reinforcement
and learning
going to improve the performance quite a
bit
all right so we talk here about a
continual learning or lifelong learning
so how does that that little sliver of
that problem help us here
so since this procedure is so simple we
can actually apply it over and over
again
so we can collect our initial grasping
data set
do our adaptation procedure right here
using the
the new data set and then given that
result we can continue doing this and
kind of change the environment again and
continue doing it again and so on so we
did this experiment
and we found that that's actually the
the performance that you get
by doing this continually is fairly
similar to the performance that we got
in the in the single uh time fine tuning
procedure
right so this is an example of a very
simple continual rl algorithm that works
very that is basically follow the leader
algorithm where we are doing fine tuning
as opposed to training in all of the
tasks
um
but here we are doing this with
reinforcement
right does this make sense is this clear
are there any questions
okay there's a question on chat when you
fine tune you only evaluate on the
respective data or in totality like
previous datasets as well yeah this is a
great question so we're only evaluating
this on the respective data so on the
data that we were fine tuning on
so this you know it is uh
potentially true that if we tested the
backward transfer so whether we can
still do well for example on a harsh
line that we tried at the very beginning
the performance might have dropped
right so it didn't really evaluate the
backward transfer
all right if there are no other
questions then one question that i would
want to ask is um this is so far we
discuss very simple algorithms so the
question is can we do better than this
right so let me briefly introduce um
one approach that that allows us to do
this and i will go over this fairly
quickly because uh we're slowly running
out of time
so um
the idea is as following can we modify
vanilla stochastic sgd stick as a
gradient descent to avoid negative
backward transfer all right so here the
address are focusing more on the
negative backward transfer so that the
concept of forgetting
and this is the paper by uh lopez pass
and ronzado
called gradient episodic memory for
continued learning
and the idea is as following
they'll store small amount of data per
task in memory so this is not
necessarily the entire data set that you
get to see but for every task you will
store a little bit of it in memory
and then when making updates for new
tasks
they will try to make sure that they
don't unlearn previous tasks
right so this is fairly common
um
and you know the the idea is kind of
fairly obvious you're trying to learn in
such a way that you don't forget about
the things that you knew
before but the question is how do you
actually accomplish this
so in this paper they try to tackle this
from an optimization perspective
and in particular they propose something
like this
uh they start with learning a predictor
so this is our predictor our function f
of theta that you're learning and this
is given a current data point and some
task
zt and you're trying to learn the the
label for that
and here we also assume that we have
memory for the cave task or for the task
zk memory that is denoted as m k
and now for for each task
we'll try to minimize the the loss as we
usually do uh for that for that new data
point for the new task
but we'll do it subject to
this constraint
the constraint right here
and what that constraint says this is
basically us trying to ensure point
number two
so what this constraint says is that um
our loss for the uh for other for
another task for the previous task zk
right that we can evaluate based on the
data that we start in the memory for
that task
should be um
uh
lesser or equal to
the loss that we had at the previous
iteration for that task so basically we
are not allowed our loss is not allowed
to go up
for the task that we are not training at
right so basically loss on the previous
task does not get worse
and in particular the way they're trying
to achieve this is that they assume the
linear
linearity of the optimization landscape
and by doing so they can express that
constraint as following as the inner
product between the gradient
with respect to uh our current task our
data point t
and the other tasks that can be
evaluated based on the memory mk
right so if that inner product
is uh non-negative that means that there
is only positive or non-transfer right
so basically if these two gradients are
perpendicular to each other that means
that when we are taking radial respect
to our current task we won't be
negatively influencing any other tasks
that are completely independent
and if that inner product is positive
that means that by taking uh the loss
for our task by taking the gradient
towards uh
that makes our task better we'll be also
making other tasks better at the same
time
all right and they tried to ensure it
for all of the previous tasks
and then they formulated and solve it as
a quadratic program
all right so a little bit about the
experiments they tried uh three
different experiments that are quite
common in this uh literature such as
amnest permutations where they're
permuting different pixels in the amnest
digits in this images
they also tried different rotations of
eminence digits that are given to you in
sequence
as well as
c4 100 where
they were assuming that each task would
involve five new classes
all right uh the total memory size that
they were using was uh 5012 examples
that was split among
the tasks that they were considering
and here are some of the results
so first i would like you to focus on
the pure accuracy so one of the things
that we discussed was how would you
measure a continual learning algorithm
you just look at look at the accuracy of
the algorithm and here you can see that
their method called gm
or gem achieves really good accuracy and
then it also presents positive backward
transfer as well as pos slightly
positive for almost zero forward
transfer
but then more interestingly you can see
the result on the right here where they
show
how that performance declines or how
does performance change after you after
seeing more and more tasks so here on
the x-axis we are seeing the task number
or the number of tasks you get you you
saw so far
and on the y-axis is the performance of
task number one
right so at this point you learn task
number one this was your original
performance and as you get to see more
and more tasks your performance stays
more or less constant it doesn't drop
because you're
learning with this constraint that
prevents you from uh
from forgetting
all right
but hopefully we'll get to the end
um
so then um they also evaluated this on
endless rotations and showed very
similar results as well as uh c4 100
where we can see that this curve stays
high as opposed to the other curves that
drop quite a bit uh because they're
subject to the to negative transfer the
negative backward transfer
right and one thing to consider when
looking at papers that talk about
continual learning and propose these
algorithms is that sometimes the
assumptions that they make and the
algorithms that they introduce they
don't necessarily apply to the
particular experiments that they were
running so in this case if we took a
step back
and we looked at the the assumptions
that they started with for you can't
just store all the data for all the
previous tasks
this is not necessarily true in this
case you're operating on this
digits and you can fairly easily store
all the images that you get to see so
some of the assumptions maybe don't
match with the experimental domain and
this is something to pay attention to
and this is quite tricky to do to find
the right experimental domain that is
kind of realistic and shows the
the properties of your algorithm
right and there are also approaches that
do this using metal learning that try to
avoid negative backward transfer through
that
and uh here are some papers that i uh
they would suggest you to take a look at
that that try to do this
all right so
in the last 10 minutes or so
um
we will talk about revisiting the
problem statement from the meta learning
perspective so how can we change that
problem statement such that we can apply
some of our mental learning algorithms
that we learned about
um
so that so that it's the the problem
statement is a little bit more tailored
towards those and it's i think more
makes more sense in general
are there any questions at this point
all right
in the meantime i'll quickly
um
adjust my charger just one second
all right
um
[Music]
there's one quick question in the chat
asking about snail which is the simple
neural attentive middle ear
um sail reminds me of continual learning
is an example of continuous lighting
right so maybe that's um
a question that you chelsea can say
something about since you've covered
snail before what they think yeah i can
i can take that so
um the snail algorithm it is
really a metal learning algorithm that
kind of can adapt to a data set using an
attention-based architecture uh
like carl we'll just we'll discuss in a
minute you can actually kind of take
metal learning algorithms and apply them
to online settings but the snail
algorithm itself is not a lifelong
learning algorithm because it just
adapts to a fixed data set rather than
like an evolving
evolving stream of data
all right thank you um are there any
other questions
great okay
so
uh let's talk about how we can revisit
the lifelink learning problem statement
from the metal learning perspective
so the original online learning
formulation
that was introducing in these two papers
um focuses on a very specific setting
where we have to perform sequence of
tasks while minimizing static regret so
what that means is that you're given
tasks in sequence
and your performance is measured as soon
as you're given a new task right so you
don't have any additional um
time to kind of adapt to this task you
will the clock will start ticking or
will start measuring your performance as
soon as you get to see that new task
so it's basically tries to measure the
zero shot performance the better you are
at being really good at this test
straight away the better that metric
will be
but more realistically what we would
want to do is to be presented the task
and then given a little bit of time to
learn the new task to adapt to the new
task and then being evaluated on the
tasks right so we want to get a little
bit of time to just figure out for the
task test and then and then be evaluated
on this
so we will do this over time and slowly
learn next task and next task and so on
and then we want to evaluate the
performance of it as opposed to
evaluating the performance straight away
zero shot
and we also want to do it such that
initially we start learning quite slowly
but eventually it gets faster and faster
so we can learn new tasks much more
rapidly the more tasks we are given
all right so um in this paper um the
address proposed to uh formulate an
online meta learning problem
where we try to efficiently learn a
sequence of tasks from a non-stationary
distribution
so in that case
the uh the performance the evaluation
will be done after seeing a small small
amount of data right so we'll have the
short burning period where you can
quickly adapt and after that the
performance will be evaluated
so it's important to note that the
difference between these two is just an
evaluation rather than in the data
stream you're still given the tasks that
are coming in sequence but you're being
evaluated slightly differently in the
online learning case you're given a
small short burning period that allows
you to adapt a little bit
all right
so um let's talk about this online metal
learning setting and let's introduce a
simple algorithm that will remind you of
an algorithm that you have seen before
um
so for the online method learning
setting we'll iterate over tasks
and then first we'll observe this little
data set the training data set for that
the task that you're given at the
current time step and that will be the
dataset from the burning period
and then um we'll have to come up with
some update procedure that will produce
the parameters for our learner for for
our uh for our function so parameters uh
phi t for instance
and then we'll get to observe the data
point predict the label for the data
point using the parameters so the
parameters the function that this
parameter is uh
this parameterized by phi t
that is an output of our update
procedure that we get to that we get to
adjust based on our burning
period and then we'll get to observe the
label
so this is the the last part of that of
the for loop is basically equivalent to
the standard online setting where you're
observing the data point predicting the
label for it and then you observe the
label
but here the the first part allows you
to do to use that burning period to
learn a better update procedure
and the goal is similar to the goal that
we had before so we're trying to find a
learning algorithm with subliminal
regret
we defined regret before where it's the
difference between the loss of the
algorithm the commodity loss of your
algorithm minus the loss of the best
algorithm in hindsight
all right so given that the problem
setting can we apply meta learning in
this lifelong learning setting
so if we recall the file deliver
algorithm
uh the basic idea is that we will store
all the data that we've seen so far and
then we'll train on it
and then once we turn on it we'll deploy
it on the current task
so here we'll change it slightly and
we'll say we'll introduce the follow the
meta leader algorithm
or we'll store store all the data that
we've seen so far but instead of just
training it will metatrade on it to
get to a better update procedure
and then we'll run the update procedure
on the current task
right so it's very very close
uh but slightly different and
you know given that follow the meta
leader idea
what do you think are good meta learning
algorithms that would work well for that
for follow the meta leader algorithm
and uh this might be a little tricky
question so just to to guide you a
little bit
consider a setting where that our
distribution of task is non-stationary
so the tasks the new tests that you're
given are maybe a little bit out of
distribution and you need to extrapolate
a little bit
and in particular remember um at some
point chelsea was talking about a black
box metal learners versus optimization
or gradient based map learning
algorithms so
what do you think what are a good meta
learning algorithms that are well suited
for uh follow the metal leader please
either raise your hand or
you can
the chat
or you can just speak up straight away
and lstm okay so
an optimization based math learner
could be
that's one option
optimization based since all data is
available at all times and you can warm
you can do warm restarts our mammal
okay
right so in particular what i'm trying
to point to here is um i think what
chelsea mentioned in in the previous
like in one of the previous lectures is
that the optimization base the gradient
based metal learning algorithms are
potentially a little bit better at
extrapolating at finding at the task
that is a little bit out of distribution
um as opposed to the
the uh black box metal learners that are
not as good at extrapolating and and uh
they're
they're more
they're doing more of an interpolation
between the tests that you've already
seen
all right
um
so um
that online method learning paper um
introduces an algorithm that that uses
uh mammal to do this so um one of the
one of the answers in chat was was was
correct uh it basically does follow the
metal leader algorithm where we are
doing the
um the meta training using the mammal
algorithm
and they evaluate the um the algorithm
based on a sequence of
tasks
so first they do it with colored or
rotated or scaled mnus digits
they also try a task of
3d object post prediction where you're
given
viewpoints of a new object and you have
to tell what's the orientation of that
object with respect to some
frame of reference in this case this red
dot on the table
and then i also do c4 100 classification
where new classes are considered a your
task
all right so we'll look at the few
comparisons
so first comparison first baseline would
be
called
toe or t-o-e
where they just trained on all the data
that was that they've seen so far
then they'll also try to follow the
leader algorithm
which is a little bit different here
given that online math learning online
math learning setting where they get to
train on all the data so far but they
will also use the data from the
burning period to fine tune on that so
that they can take the full advantage of
the setting so this is the version of
the leader that that kind of takes
advantage of that online metal learning
setting
and then they'll also uh try training
from scratch on each one of the tasks
right and i'll just quickly show you the
the results
and
here we can see in terms of the training
efficiency so how many data points does
the algorithm require
to get to a certain performance
and here at the bot at the x-axis we see
the task index we can see that fdml
algorithm can
much efficient much more efficient than
all the other baselines and it gets more
efficient as it gets to see more and
more tasks so it's getting better and
better at learning
and then here on the right we see the
learning proficiency
which
which is basically measured after a
burning period of a hundred plus i
believe or 100 data points excuse me
uh where
you see that the performance of the of
the algorithm itself
uh or the error of the of the algorithm
itself is also the best
so it's uh
it can achieve smaller and smaller error
and as it gets to see more tasks
so in this case follow the meta leader
learns each new task faster but also
with greater proficiency
and eventually it can approach kind of
the future learning regime where you
just need a few examples to be able to
learn the human task
all right um
so we are slightly over time but i'll um
ask you for questions right after this
um so just a few takeaways that i wanted
you to
take away from this
so
uh first of all there are many flavors
of lifelong learning and they all exist
under the same name so we went through
the exercise where you kind of realized
yourself how many different versions of
lifelong learning you can come up with
and very often when you read these
papers uh they refer to it as the same
concept they're all doing lifelong
learning but the problem the specific
problem selling is slightly different so
pay attention to that
and very often defining the problem
statement itself is the hardest part of
a lifelong learning algorithm once you
have a very crisp problem statement
definition you can
relatively easily easily come up with a
with an algorithm that can look
interesting
and metal learning can be viewed as a
slice of the life and learning problem
where you're just doing adaptation to
the to the next task
and uh as we mentioned at the beginning
this is a very open area of research
this is i think one of the most
open-ended uh
kind of
one of the most open-ended lectures that
we've had here where
there's a lot of research in the area
and even the problem statement is still
being researched and that's not
very very strictly defined
um
right and this is it so uh thank you
very much are there any questions at
this point
yeah there's a question from
i
want to ask more about the example where
you have
i think it was six sawyer arms and then
you're trying to pick up a grasp object
uh in that i was wondering
if when you
you train on around uh or you find your
name 800 grass
and i was wondering um if you had tried
the
train on everything in that scenario and
uh
when you found
some evidence of benefiting from fine
tuning uh
how that would have done how that would
have compared against uh
train on everything or train from
scratch on that right yeah
yeah thank you for the question yeah
this is a really good question so
um i think maybe a few points so
first of all because we had so many
um
grasps from the
pre-training data set i think one worry
is that these 800 grasp will just
disappear in the sea of data from all
the other tasks
so it might not pay as much attention to
that new setting and i think because of
this it will probably get worse than
in the fine-tuning case
um and then secondly just from the
computation resources perspective uh
training this on the entire data set
every time will take around three to
four days on multiple machines
um
so it's just like a an unfeasible
problem or an unfeasible really uh
proposition where every time you see
some kind of change in the environment
you need to retrain and wait for three
days to to have the the policy that can
that can learn that can perform in that
new setting
so probably by the time you train the
entire algorithm that will be already uh
you'll be in a different setting and i
was just a little confused on that on
the arrows so you trained on i was
wondering why you didn't share learning
between the different uh fine tuning
tasks so like like transparency
checkerboard uh the different kinds of
grippers i was wondering why there
wasn't any shared learning between those
tasks
so by shared learning do you mean why
didn't we construct a data set that had
all of the different modifications and
try to point into that no as in why um
why the network parameters weren't
shared between the different subtasks
but they were just shared between the
main
uh tasks and the six different subtasks
right right okay yeah so let me clarify
this um
so um
the the way we were doing fine tuning is
that we would start from that original
pre-training uh
pre-trained policy
and then we'll do we'll warm start our
new policy from that so it will have the
exact same parameters and then we'll
fine-tune to the next task at this point
we'll have the parameters of that new
policy that perform quite well on that
next task and then we'll fine-tune that
one again so a worm start the next one
this and kind of keep going does that
direction matter like which you do first
would you do a second do you do more
general tasks
i had upstream more specific tasks yeah
the other way around
yeah that's a really good question we
didn't really evaluate it um at least in
terms of the order of the fine-tuning
task if i were to guess i think that the
uh it's important to pre-train on aspect
of a family of tests or as big of a data
set as possible
so that fine tuning is easier so i don't
think you should change
and start training on 800 grasps and
then find you into 800 000 grasps
but i think in terms of the order of the
fine-tuning tasks
we didn't really evaluate this but i
think that would be really interesting
and i don't really have a good intuition
what the good what the what the good
ordering would be
if you're a quick man i never understand
why um
the loss on each task would be constant
um i see
so if we if we um
assuming that each task is of similar
difficulty
um
then for and assuming that we train each
task from scratch
right or each data point from scratch
um
the loss that we would get after
training assuming the same difficulty
should probably be very similar across
different tasks right so i give you a
data point or a bunch of data points and
i ask you to train on it and
these are very similar to each other so
after you train on it
probably the loss between all of them
will be very close
does that does that make sense it does
yeah right so then if you're
cumulatively adding that loss every
single time step that will be a linear
function of the number of things
yeah and okay
and just if maybe if you have another 30
seconds what does it mean for it to be
locally linear and is that and when the
the la paz paper solved it i think
uh they said they come in as a qp
uh and is that an assumption that's
justified in general
yeah so i think overall reasoning about
the optimization landscape of um
these
uh of of neural networks of having
millions of grounders is really really
difficult these are highly non-linear
landscapes where it's very difficult to
say something about them and there's a
few papers that try to characterize this
but it's overall
really really tricky
um
the the local linear assumptions
uh assumes that uh at least for the next
gradient step the landscape is linear
and that's an assumption that people
commonly commonly make in order to make
any sort of analysis how a gradient
would influence other tasks for example
and this was done in a few papers
either that do multitask learning or
continual learning but that's a fairly
common assumption i would say
okay it's kind of necessary if you want
to reason about the landscape
there's also a question that i was
answering in the chat
um
but you could also give your opinion
uh
are there works that
study
basically the the
um the task order and the difficulty of
the tasks versus an iid distribution
um
sorry
ordering the task based on the
difficulty versus an iid
distribution
yeah um
there's no particular papers that come
to mind right now um if i were to guess
yeah i'm not familiar with any theory on
this or any even in well i guess we can
come up with some kind of intuition and
place for reinforcement learning
problems
where you would probably want to start
with tasks that can help explore for the
next tasks
or that are a little bit broader but the
the next task that you want to adjust to
um
but i think this is more of an intuition
than something that
has been has been truly shown
and in case of the supervised learning
problem i'm not sure if
um if if there's any research on the
ordering of tasks there
yeah in the supervised learning setting
i added one a link to one paper that
might be relevant it shows basically if
you pre-train on one thing
and then train on another thing uh that
pre-training task can actually
deteriorate performance for later tasks
in some settings
yeah i think this would probably depend
quite a bit on the application and what
the specific tests are so it's difficult
to say something general about this but
uh yeah it's a really interesting
question
okay i think we can end there